we'll start with the fact that ganabri
was at Arsenal for four years so he's an
Arsenal player he had arsene Wenger
there as his manager four years and then
they loaned him out and he just said
have you seen more he throw that up and
he said come on look at this and he just
and he was apparently a county Javelin
thrower it's not the fact that we're
going to sell him for a profit it's the
fact that Crouch is going to keep us in
the Premier League for the next three or
four years that's the investment it says
Gaff and I go Rick and he goes
you worry too much
I go
and he went that's why you got no air
mate
would he turns to me he says gaffer
whatever you do don't put me on please
and I said what he says I can't play as
well as well Ryan's just played
[Laughter]
again
[Music]
what's happening everyone and welcome to
sports Bible stories I'm Rory Jennings
and I'm asmerizer and today we welcome
the one and only Tony pulis onto the
show thank you
no problem it's really really appreciate
you coming on thank you
um what you've been up to you haven't
been working now since the chef or
Wednesday job which was what December
2020. now I've um I've had a great time
actually uh I've always in my life in my
management life lived away from home so
I've had a house in Bournemouth
um and all the clubs I think it's 11 is
11 12 clubs I've had I've always
um kept the family Debbie and the
children down there and traveled so to
actually uh have the opportunity and
chance to to actually settle down in a
you know we've got a beautiful house
down there on the coast so yeah
um there's been lots of stuff I've done
lots of
um stuff with different people
um that have kept me busy obviously I do
the radio TV sometimes and bits and
pieces
um I keep in touch with the football
um but no it's been I've enjoyed I keep
myself busy I'm not one of them that can
sit around
um so there's always something going on
and have you got any interest in getting
back into management
um I would be reluctant to go back in as
a manager
um I've had people ring me and ask for a
little bit of advice and would they pop
in and see them and do bits and pieces
and I've done that with one or two
sports as well not just football so that
has been interesting
um the other sports
um that I've got involved with have been
um interesting and different in some
ways but in the majority of uh of
instances
um building a a sports program but when
you're looking for like to get into a
Club what's like the key things for you
what's what's important when choosing a
club well as a manager yeah
the the most important thing in is the
chairman really is the owner
um I think that the games changed since
you know I was managing in the 90s which
is was probably before some of you were
born
um and it you know it's it's Washington
then there was a manager a secretary and
the chairman
so there was no one in between really
the manager and the the chairman apart
from the secretary who ran the finances
so you you could actually get things
done uh pretty quickly and also you were
given the opportunity and time to build
something because there was no noise in
between if you have a look at today you
know the layers in between the coach as
they call them now or the manager it's
just extraordinary and you know when
you've got different layers and
different people involved there's always
going to be a conflict somewhere in what
you want to do and what you want to
achieve as a manager and I find that um
that that is a a big issue for managers
today or for coaches today and if I was
starting again today whereas I've always
had people who have uh you know come in
and been coaches
um I would definitely definitely have
someone now who worked above me came in
with me but worked above me worked at
boardroom level
and looked after that side
of the business or the the club while I
got on with the the football side
because I don't think
um no disrespect to the people who were
in positions but I don't think there's a
strong enough bond between them and the
managers when it comes to a manager
being sacked I think if if someone came
in with me and knew that if I got the
sack he got the sack I think he'd fight
a lot more than the person who's there
it was not going to get the sack when I
get the sack and is going to see me off
and then most probably see the next
manager off and the next manager off
um and I think I think
uh personally and and again this is is
just me
um my thoughts and I've said it before I
think if Frank Lampard had someone at
Chelsea
above working in that area he most
probably would have kept his job a
little bit longer than what he did
um and you know and I'm not being
disrespectful to anybody here I just
think someone who is with a manager or a
coach and knows his job's on the line if
he loses it works and will try a lot
harder to keep him in the job than maybe
one or two who are in that position who
are not affected by the manager being
attacked so pick the chairman not the
club yeah would be the would be the
strategy you get listen I've I've had uh
numerous Chairman's uh numerous people
in charge
um and there's you know you find
when you get into a football club you
find things
um can be different and I've always
thought that the relationship you know I
I look back at Norman award at
Bournemouth who's my first chairman
um the club were in a lot of financial
trouble Norman was very honest with me
very very understanding
um in respect of the the work I had to
do it was laid out in front of me
um and we had to try and get the
finances right he was honest and
straightforward
um and then I've had other other people
you go in and you know they say one
thing
um and then they do other things and you
know I've just always been one that if I
didn't think it was right then I don't
think I've ever hung around too long
so Tony we're going to try and get to
know you a bit better yeah we've got
some quick fire questions for you if
that's all right yep who did you support
when you were growing up
Cardiff and Man City uh man united sorry
man city
Cardiff Cardiff and Man United
both yeah well Cardiff was
um I was in Newport it should have been
Newport really but I I was brought up
with toshak playing at Cardiff before he
got sold to Liverpool long long time ago
so I I would go to ninian park when I
had the opportunity and a chance and
watch those games and really you know
that was my first taste of you know I
thought Lynn Cardiff were a big club and
what was the man united man united was
more from my father I think and and they
had the great team then the team in 68
that won the European Cup with best Lord
Charlton you know One Nevada team the
father yeah
and uh what about your favorite football
and now favorite footballer now
um I I think uh Harry Kane is is a
fantastic player
um I think they're over a period of time
he has shown the consistency at the top
top level
um
for everybody to have tremendous respect
for him and do you think he'll he'll
stay at Tottenham I know there's a lot
of talk about him leaving potentially do
you see him leaving I mean you know that
that would be uh that would be an i I'd
be amazed if he left
um but I've been amazed loads of times
in my life with football did you have a
favorite manager growing up
um well Jimmy schooler was at Cardiff
you you lot won't know him and when I
was I and I did a few stories about
Jimmy
um it was a Scotsman
um
very passionate uh and then obviously
Matt Busby those two teams that I'd
follow samat and and was probably Jimmy
um they were the two that that I knew
more than than the others and what about
uh favorite manager now
favorite manager now I think the Premier
League are very fortunate to have
and I've had most probably some of the
greatest managers of my era uh
especially so it's been it's been a a
pleasure to to manage against pep and uh
uh you know Antonio and you go on
fengers was obviously fabulous at
Arsenal all the clubs who have who have
been successful club and and them I've
been fortunate to to manage against them
the only one that that really is has
missed out has been the
uh Athletico Simeone you know who you
know look at listen and and people talk
to me about him and he's most probably
the only one that slipped through the
net and hasn't managed in England
um it would have been lovely to have
seen him come to England and see how he
set a club up and set aside up do you
think it would work do you think he
would have yeah I think I think the the
top top managers given the opportunity
um uh you know you know they they know
how to win they know Eddie Howe Yeah
Eddie Howe went out to learn from him I
think you know in his in in the Gap that
he took between the Bournemouth jobs
making Newcastle I think he went to
study Diego simeone's approach did you
ever do anything like that
I went out um I went out a couple of
times and watched uh different
um different people work
when I was at Stoke I went out to
Germany
um and did a bit there and and in Spain
um just watched the training watched the
setup had to look at things and
especially the youth development side of
it as well and seeing the difference
between or tried to find the difference
between what the Germans and the Spanish
do compared to OS our setup but that was
10 12 years ago since then obviously the
academies have come in
and we're spending now an absolute
fortune on them on developing young
players the academies have have become
an industry within an industry
um and you know in in some ways a bigger
they have more you know more staff
there's a lot of money now invested in
in the production of young young kids so
yeah I think we've most probably we've
got uh uh an industry
um that football invests more than any
other country in the world in so I'm
very fortunate talking to Germany we've
seen a lot of the young English players
going out there do you think that's the
right move like the academy players I
don't think the Germans are Daft and I
think they've most probably
um understood the the the workings that
are going on in England in respect to
the academy and see the problem you've
got with all the top academies if you
look at Chelsea uh Man City and that
they need to win I don't know at the
moment Chelsea ain't doing that but they
need they they they need they need to
win
so they in respect of all the money that
they're they're plowing into the young
players managers are coming in and
especially when abrahimovic was there
you know they they needed to win
trophies and to blood young players and
take a chance with young players they
didn't do it very often and I think
Chelsea have have produced a lot of very
very good players and then they've left
because they couldn't get first in
football and I I think if you look at
the big clubs there's a lot of good
talent that never get the opportunity to
play in their first teams because of the
demands of that team to win and win and
win not to develop
um and that's that's an interesting fact
it's also uh if you're clever enough
um as a person who's got who's got
enough money to invest it's a real good
place to fish because you will get some
real quality players who haven't broke
through yet
um but would become good players given
the opportunities at the Southampton
model they've been looked at cities
Youth products and yeah I I yeah and you
know that that that is most probably if
like I say if you look at the top top
clubs the money they're paying
um to bring young players from South
America all over the world and put them
into their academies they're bringing
families over you know they're settling
them in and everything else they they
are investing enormous amounts of money
so if you're with a a smaller club or a
club that's got a little bit of money
instead of chasing your tail all over
the world really and truthfully if you
could sit and study four or five of the
top Premier League clubs who invest
hundreds of millions of pounds in their
academies then um there's there's
certainly Talent there away from
football a bit Tony what's your biggest
interest away from the game
um history uh I've always been very very
[Music]
um
Keen to read about uh leaders
um going back you know
way way back you know the Roman Empire I
spent a lot of time on Napoleon
um really interested in a little kid who
was born in Corsica and then ends up you
know producing and and being in charge
of a great Empire actually taking an
army into Moscow and sitting in Moscow
how long did he sit there for a couple
of months until the weather turned he
got chased out so you know there's not
many people who have taken armies into
into Russia and gone all the way uh to
Moscow so he interested me as a as a
laddu to come from quite a wealthy
family in Corsica but then had been
placed in a school in France and I think
at the time Corsica was split between
Italy and France what what half of them
wanted to be Italians Alpha wanted to be
French for him to be stuck into an
academy as such a young lad and then to
go through and and you know it was
interesting to see the steps he took to
eventually get where where he got and
that was you know a lot of people say he
was a
a tyrant and everything else I thought
he was a very very clever clever man and
a fabulous tactician on the battlefield
do you see a bit of yourself in there
not Berlin No not
I I do they interest me the people who
have come from nothing you know I've
read loads of books you know
um uh Shackleton you know the the
endurance I don't know if
um that that is just an amazing book
where you know the the you know the
Rolex Expedition Falls to bits when they
get caught in ice
and I think he had 38 39 people with him
and I might even be more than that and
after 18 months in in the most
horrendous conditions you know they they
he ends up bringing them all back safe
and sound you know that the ship had
broken up they only had two small rowing
boats
um you know they had to get to Elephant
Island and from there to to I think it
was Georgia
um just extraordinary you know that
these people are just extraordinary
people who lived in obviously a
different era had different values
um to us and different uh motivations
but um yeah you know people who have
done and achieved things
um interest me huge what about uh within
the game any career regret
um
I left South South Wales when I was 16
years of age I was brought up in a big
family down on the docks only a couple
of streets away from the the doc Gates
there was four boys in one bed two girls
who never bed mum and dad in a little
box room so there was eight of us living
in a little house
uh and we didn't have
um a lot but we had everything the
community was Fab lips was fabulous
Community I was brought up into
to have the opportunity at 16 years of
age of going to a professional football
club
um and I always say this to people I can
remember looking out the window in that
uh carriage and saying I'm not going to
come back I really really want to make a
goal of this and 50 odd years later
yeah 50 odd years later nearly I'm still
doing stuff in football so have I got
regrets yeah none whatsoever it's been
like this I've just been so blessed
that's such a nice Outlook no no 100 and
um I I know the answer this well I'm
sure I will but are you a tracksuit
manager or a suit manager yeah
what's your favorite tracksuit yeah no
no no
yeah I think the Caps were more of a
problem for me I used to I used to be
very choosy with uh well caps I wore uh
the tracksuits were okay
um
and at the time when I was managing I
could get into some of them now I've put
a bit of Timber on them
what was the proudest moment of your
career greatest achievements I think
being in the game for so long and
enjoying it for so long uh regrets and
now I don't I just
you know it's I'm not one of them I
don't you know I leave a football club
and I'll leave it behind and I leave the
memories and and I try and wash away all
the bad stuff and just concentrate on
all the good stuff and be really
positive with it and you know I'm 65 now
so you know I just wanna
go through life enjoy myself I don't
know what I'm doing here but you know
yeah
Jesus
I know who's the most influential person
on your career oh I I had a few I I
think um and again it's a great miss in
football at the moment when I went to
Bristol Rovers as a uh I'll start at 15
16. uh we had wonderful mentors we had
wonderful people senior people around
the club who were full-time and
part-time but they were real football
people genuine football people but also
you know football has always reflected
um you know life and you know the
community out there I think I'm a great
believer that it it felt like it when I
was younger it pulled away
um or it pulled with with everything
everything just you know sort of like
came together and I I was taught from a
very very young age about respect about
discipline
um and they were massive things at
Bristol you know there's the bill
Georgian who's it bills in his 60s
um old Bobby Campbell not the one who
was at Chelsea
um
Gordon Bennett Colin Dobson not all you
know Don Mixon was that was my you gave
me my debut when I was younger and I'm
if I'm missing people I do it by my
clients I I do apologize but they were
all great mentors they would pick you up
if you did anything wrong they would
pick you up
um and they would encourage you if
things you know had a very very bad
injury when I was 21 to my ankle and I
was out for nearly nine months and you
know plastered up the top of my leg and
then below my my knee and and to be
honest I there was a great feeling I
couldn't play again and I'd finished the
season by playing one game in the third
team on a very hard bumpy uh pitch
um at Eastville and I struggled and I
really struggled and after the game the
club gave me an extra year this contract
used to get one years then they give you
any they gave me an extra year and I
think they gave me an extra year
thinking at the back of their minds that
I might not
get through it and that that gave me so
much confidence you know I never worked
so hard in my life that close season to
get myself at a level
anyone ever given you any advice that
you still live by today I yeah I uh Alex
stock who's a wonderful manager and
managed actually in Italy and managed
QPR to a cup final and Fulham or Fulham
I think it was it Fulham or I think it
was full he took to a cup final Alex was
uh uh uh actually fought in the second
world war
um with Montgomery
um in the desert he was one of the
Desert Rats so
when I was young young manager starting
at Bournemouth Alex lived down there he
was actually in a care room and I used
to pop in and see him
um and sit down he loved he had a they'd
built him a a lovely greenhouse and he
used to grow his own tomatoes and this
that and the other and he's a very very
upstanding person shirt and so I always
with a jacket and you know real stickler
and spoke really you know not Posh but
proper English not like us and Alex said
to me two things
he said always believe your own eyes
don't don't take any notice of anybody
else apart from yourself and make your
own decisions and stand and fall by
those decisions and that was something
I've always done and if like I say if I
smell something that I didn't think was
right
then I it'd be very very unusual for me
to to sort of like hang on too long if I
didn't think it was right right well
you're perhaps uh renowned for your time
at Stoke and of course it was that big
phrase a cold wet Tuesday night at Stoke
yeah first of all how do you feel about
that and um was that something you you
and the players were aware of
I think the story at Stoke really
started with our first premier league
game at Bolton we got beat three one I
think Gary Mason was managed at polton
at the time and Paddy Power wrote us off
I think they paid up on us being
relegated
um that was the first weekend
um and it was just it was just the the
thing that I needed it was just the uh
impetus to get the city together and I
went on the radio I went in the papers I
did a lot of media that week and just
made it it's us
it's not the team they're putting Stoke
City down that's the city you lot out
there and us
um and it was it was something that I
just built on and built on we played
Villa our first home game beat fella 3-2
I think I think Mama scored late on from
a long throw
um
that set her off and it was just we
built it from there really but it was
you know people say and I've been asked
oh you must have thought you know it was
it was you're going to be up against it
having got beat up Bolton it was the
best thing that happened because of that
what Paddy periden can you settle this
debate once and for all yeah could
Leonel Messi do it on a cold Tuesday
night instead couldn't you he could do
it anyway
play football yeah yeah any any you know
and he he just absolutely extraordinary
player
um and it'd be you know he might not get
involved as much as maybe he might do in
a warm climate but he do two or three
things during the game of win the game
yeah that's what he is it's just a
special special person would you say
he's the greatest of all time I know
there's always that debate no I've I've
spoke to people about this see I'm I'm a
50s baby so you know I I can remember
Pele
um Pele Maradona then I'd go Messi
Ronaldo
they would be
a full standout and then you've got you
know again
it's great players of their time you
know that that's that's a thing I don't
think you can you can really go I can
remember Pele so he was great at that
time I can remember Maradona so he was
great at that time Messi Ronaldo Croy
you know all all you know they they
they're just wonderful players special
special players what was it about
Arsenal you used to beat them every time
you'd play them every single time you
used to get under their skin it was an
amazing achievement yeah I think that
acid now that's enormously by you know
putting comments certain comments in the
paper that we actually picked up on you
know I I I during my management
career I'd always try and find an angle
um to play against different teams and
even make I'd make things up you know
I'd come in one day and say you know
have you heard what that player has said
about you and about the football club
and the players haven't said nothing
completely it was just it was just a
motivational tool trolling yeah that
that I I would use you know I'd say the
club had said or the you know the the
club had said that you know they hated
coming to our place you know we weren't
that good we weren't this we weren't
that and it was a load of nonsense and
the lads used to buy into it and you
know I I seriously after every game I
would make sure I got the local papers
so if we played say Blackburn I'd won
the local paper sent down to to make
sure I could read and and find little
bits and pieces and then just keep that
for when we played Blackburn again and
then you know so I'd have those little
motivational I always wanted an angle I
always thought that players
um especially after maybe two years the
two years in the Premiership we needed a
little bit more motivational at times to
play against because we'd come become a
little bit more established and then
you've got yourself in a situation where
when we were playing the likes of maybe
mid-table teams we were go we were
playing at Stoke and we were expected to
win and that expectation wasn't with us
the first two years we were always The
Underdogs and then it just gradually we
become more established so I had to find
a way of really getting into the players
and and getting that little bit extra
that was the difference between winning
and losing going back to Arsenal I just
think it was the supporters you know
that they'd be there about hour and a
half before the game picking next spot
trying to get as close to arson as
possible they could give him some stick
but you know that it was just it was you
know special special days and um I have
nothing against uh Wenger at all
um Arsenal's fabulous club and you know
one of the the great clubs when I was
younger it was the Arsenal you know
people used to tell nice some people
still say it and you know you look at
what they're doing today where arteta's
done there which is fabulous
um so Rory is an app uh well renowned
for his long-terms you mentioned it
earlier as well yeah
um what was that what was that like you
know did you every time that you saw it
happen would you still Amaze you or
would it just be like right we know it's
that it didn't train him the laps were
having a I think it was the promotion
yeah promotion I'm not sure or the first
year in the premise it might have been
the promotion here
and they had a competition who could
throw it the furthest and we'd finish
training there was four or five of them
over
in the corner and David Kemp would work
with me for years I had Dave there Jerry
Francis Mark Connor
um a panic Reedy I had all those people
anyway can we come over to me and he
just said have you seen Maury throw that
up
and oh no
and
look at this and he just
and he was apparently a county Javelin
thrower
he's got he's got
um
loose
uh what is it called your shoulder
double jointed on your shoulders so he
could actually get you know get so much
power
from it and I was just flabbergasted
well I actually give him Italian off and
why haven't you showed us
and it was it just it just went from
there you know we worked we worked
really really hard on we didn't just
throw it in I see teams
today uh with long throws his funny
Arsenal I've got a lot of person who
throws it long now as well so you know I
see people you know Liverpool got a
throwing yeah yeah so you know the stick
that we used to take is quite funny now
um but no we we used to really set it up
and work out on our set play so would
you tactically do that would you try and
win throw-ins at a particular no no no
when we got throwings we'd work on where
we wanted players to be and areas to to
attack and where we thought
and teams would be vulnerable was they
just lump it up to crouchy and then get
the flick on the Crouch and remember
that goalie scored was against man city
right yeah yeah we didn't even touch the
ground oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
what a great player it was great but did
you ever sign players with the tactic in
mind no it wasn't like no I I mean the
other thing is what I'd like to say
about Rory is Rory played near over 500
games
um he was a tremendous player Jack and
played a lot of Premier League games and
you don't play a lot of Premier League
games you know just being a person who
can throw the ball in
um I'm a great fabulous lad you know I
had some wonderful wonderful plays at
Stoke you know some real
um gritty determined characters or you
could you could build a club with yeah
his son's doing well at the city isn't
he yeah uh Liam's just I think he had a
long spell at Stoke and now he's just
going to Preston um scored a few goals
uh they tell me he's a he's a good
talent yeah yeah and talking to stoke uh
you got them in there first and only FA
Cup Final what was that occasion like
you know managing the team yeah it was
obviously the game before was against
Bolton was the semi-finals the the when
we won 5-0 was
absolutely this world that was the first
time that uh
I think the club had been to Wembley
since 72 1972 so
um
you know for oh no they might have gone
in the playoffs I'm not sure but anyway
that was a wonderful occasion and we
tried to replicate it with the man city
um game and unfortunately
um you know they beat us one nil I think
we put in a a real when you look at city
now and and what they were going to
develop into
um
you know we missed two really good
chances Cameron missed a great
one-on-one chance before they scored
before
um uh what's names called the big tall
Midfield player oh great sorry Tory yeah
great player
um he scored the winning goal so
yeah please for the supporters that they
had two visits to Wembley disappointed
that we lost you know it is there's no
satisfaction after you get beat how do
you prepare for a game like that like
you're playing Manchester City all of
the riches of the club you're up against
Pep Guardiola obviously it's it's a
mismatch in terms of the scale of what
the club's when we when we went to
um the semi-final
uh what we decided to do we trained
Monday and Tuesday properly uh when I
say properly similar to what we did
um and at Wednesday off and we arranged
the train to go down to Wembley we got a
bus waiting for us at Waterloo Station I
think it's water two or whatever it is
whatever it goes into now one more to
Lou
um anyway we've got a bus waiting for us
um and we went to Wembley we didn't tell
anyone we were going we just turned up
with a bus drove into Wembley packed it
under the under the covers got the
players up in the stands walked them on
the pitch and everything else with our
tracksuits so they got a feel for the
place and then once we'd had a walk
around and look around we then took them
for an Italian meal in London and went
back and prepared Thursday and Friday
for Bolton and then um you know the good
the great thing about the Bolton game
The Players had come and seen me and
said oh now that we're in a semi-final
can we have suits
and I said no you can't okay you're
joking
it's a semi-final get to a final you're
gonna have a suit but that's a Winner's
mentality I like that that's not that's
you know having one for the semi-final
of course we turned up in our track
suits and Bolton have got brand new
suits with roses so again my team talk
was there you go made really easy
um and you know I ripped into ripped
into a few little um verses
um and you know it just it was a
fantastic day any newspaper clippings
that you had about them I I I had I I've
got or I did have you know bucket full
of stuff that I would uh you know I'd go
in and just say to Kempy you know I'm
gonna
say this and I'm going to say that and
pay for me and go where'd you get that
from there Dave I've got my sources you
know I know I mean you know like I say
it I thought
it helped so that cup final obviously
didn't go as you hoped but the club
ended up embarking on a European tour
yeah Europe was was fabulous but you
know it was It was a you know great
occasion and and the the last game
against Valencia obviously we played at
10 at the bet 365 Stadium
and uh you know they they
the manager at Aston Villa now and Emery
Emery was was in charge of Valencia and
they they beat this one nil they played
really well that night they they really
really contained us we didn't have as
many chances as what we were hoping for
and they they looked really strong
um and we'd we'd had quite a tough
season I think that year we played over
50 odd games we got to a quarter finals
of the FA Cup that year Liverpool
knocked us out 2-1 at anfield I think we
were one nil up and we missed another
great chance to go to nil up they beat
us we did quite well in the league cup
and then we had these I think we had 12
games in Europe all in all so there was
still a concern about the league at that
time you know as it is now there's so
many
um variations that can happen and you
can drop into a bad run of games or you
can drop into a really good runner
runner games for the second game I made
a lot of changes
um and I think a lot of supporters were
disappointed with the changes we made
but actually
we went to Valencia and played really
really well and apart from a very very
poor display from the referee and the
fact that kenwyn missed two or three
really I can see the header he's missed
after about 10 minutes now from a call
now and and you know he'd bury it nine
times out of ten he missed that chance
we played really well support is then
you know some of the support was
criticized me and I I accept criticism
but the criticism I would give myself
was
I should have played that team in the
first leg
I'm not I'm not I should have played in
both legs because they were fresh and we
at that that team Upson Woodgate uh up
front was Fuller uh Cameron Jerome you
know good players you know the the the
the like I say the the supporters took
it as a second team but when you look at
that team that team was a good team and
had more experience in Europe some of
them than what the team had played
against Valencia wrong but the
experiences were were just absolutely
fantastic fantastic and then off the
back of that uh Peter Coates the scrubby
is one of the best managers he's ever
had how proud were you when you had
those kind of comments and no but I had
a great relationship with Peter I I
actually
um uh you know obviously I started that
that first year and a half two years I
actually had the Icelandic owners as the
manager before Peter then took over
um but Peter was always always there in
the background we'd sit down we just
seemed to get on really really well and
I've got the greatest respect for him
and his family I think well I don't
think I'm absolutely convinced that
eventually they'll get back in the
Premiership I think his son now John was
taking the Reigns and he's found he's
had a difficult time but Peter had a
difficult time at Stoke as well before
all this success come along so you know
John will be learning learning on the
job but he's a determined man
um and he knows his football and I think
eventually that hopefully fingers
crossed that that they do get back to
the Premier League and they bring their
success to that City that these are the
people deserve an incredible
acknowledgment there so refer to you as
the best manager in stoke's history well
yeah you know that's uh that's lovely
for Peter to say you know I'd
you know I'd say that he was part of it
that you know me getting that Accolade
you know he he has to take a lot of
credit for that you know the players
that you signed it seemed to elevate for
Stoke didn't it it went from it went
from being
players that didn't necessarily have
that element of Glamor to quite
Hollywood signings well I'd crouched
yeah I think I think the the great thing
about it was that and and this is what
happens in this country is perception
and once a person's got a perception of
someone it's very very difficult for him
like I say believe in your eyes you know
there's that it could be doing something
completely different and because the
conception of perception is this they
just think it's this you know it's black
I was told it was white and you know
that so they they're set in their ways I
think if you look at the team and we
used to chuckle about it a little bit we
had Etherington and pennant white you
know people like crouchy John Walters we
had a really really good side there in
the end and you know we we played some
really really good stuff but we never
said anything everybody said oh it's
kick it in London bit stuff yeah yeah
and before you know before you know
as that great saying about could Messi
play there you know clubs clubs who come
in and teams will come in and getting
beat before the game started because
they thought it was going to be
it was a lot more than that and and how
Hands-On were you with those transfers
obviously did you go to the channel I I
had um I had uh because I had my
relationship with Peter
um I had a big say in all those
transfers that those players the
majority of those players while all
those players that when I was there
um it would have been signed you know
I'll tell you now Crouch is one
um you know with Harry had rung me and
said Peter was available I think Abby
had moved back up to Manchester so Peter
wanted to move from London to go
um go with Abby um
so I said to H listen we can't I don't
think we'd be able to afford his wages I
don't think we'll be able to afford the
the fee but we'd be interested Harry
come back to me and said the club would
would try and work something out if your
Club could raise a certain amount
so I rang Peter up and Pete said okay
see you know where you can go and then
come back to me when it gets a little
bit more solid
so I I went back to Peter and said I
think we're you know at the stage where
you know you can
do solid by the week and do it or no and
about five minutes late it rang me up
and he said to me
people are asking me and I'm taking it
people behind him the chief executive
and whoever are asking me spending all
that money on a play you'll get no
return is it a good deal
and I said to Peter Peter it's not the
fact that we're going to sell him for a
profit it's the fact that Crouch is
going to keep us in the Premier League
for the next three or four years that's
the investment and event thank you very
much put the phone down
you know there were a lot of players
that arrived with a sort of similar
profile in terms of who they were the
way that they approached the game maybe
even the way that they approached life
uh Jonathan Waters Glenn wheel and Ryan
shawcross they're they're big characters
would you put a lot of stock in not only
the footballer but oh man everything
character was was everything I I took I
took it this is the way I worked I took
it on building blocks and those building
blocks were players that you give three
four-year contracts to so Shaw cross
Booth begovitz Sorensen uh wheel and you
know white Dean Whitehead people John
Walters you know people like that they
were building they were solid citizens
they they were ones that you every week
they turned up you know irrespective
though it was going they gave their best
all the time Glenn Whelan is a wonderful
example every every year we got promoted
we bought Clem from Sheffield Wednesday
every we got promoted I wanted to get
better I brought what I thought was
lettering Within
weeks Glenn stepped above that person I
brought in then I'd bring someone else
in and think we you know we can do
better than Glenn and then each step
again and I have so much respect for
that boy over a period of time where he
always
he got better and he took the challenge
a lot of people would have gone off and
thrown it and thrown the Baton away
Whelan just kept going and going and I
have the so much respect for the kid for
doing that but just quickly so those
were long term and then you'd bring
people in like pennant and and Jermaine
was a terrific player and you couldn't
question his ability or anything like
that but he was a little scallywag so he
was he was a 2-3 window yeah sign in so
you get the best out of him and then
when he dropped a little bit which
that's what Jermaine did that was his
character when he dropped the bit you'd
move him on so you'd have I'd have that
building blocks they stay and you'd have
one or two that would give the place a
lift
for a short period and then you would
cut and look for other people so did you
have that back in your mind like they
will eventually leave at some point even
no matter how I I didn't back in my mind
I added in in more I'd
what I did in respect of my my prep for
bringing players in I knew their
characters I knew what they were like on
the field off the field every everything
that they did and and didn't do and got
up to then I I you know I knew what they
were doing and I knew you know what they
were like and the promotion you we had
you know we took craze well
um and crazies again fabulous lad and we
played him wide left and the Laura
forwards is sent forward Laura forwards
would have said I can't play wide left
he was absolutely fantastic I think he
got 15 goals from left-hand side work
this socks off unbelievable Liam
Lawrence again you know those two were
were just extraordinary in that
championship
uh that promotion side you know they
never got the credit they deserved you
know they they were fabulous and then
you add Fuller Ricardo to that I had a
very very special relationship with Rick
Rick was one of those where you go well
three you know window and then get rid
of him
I just
not fell in love with him but I just
understand I just done nothing wrong
with that yeah I just understood his
character and what what he needed to to
you know rev the engine up because when
he played
he was exceptional he scored goals that
if he had been at the top three or four
Club you know they'd be talking about it
now but that one that berkamp one well
yeah that you know the the goals that
Rick's called and the the amount of
games he just took by the Scruff of the
neck
um and won by doing something special
was and the players accepted him you
know he he he was Jamaican every day was
Christmas day
he just you know he'd float in and he'd
float out but the large The Lads you
know I've got that great story I've told
it so many times we're playing in
promotion here and we've got wolves
wolves a third
West Brom will win in the league with uh
Tony was manager Tony Mulberry was it
we're second wolves the third and we've
got a game with about five games to go
six games to go this season at molyneux
we've sold six and a half thousand
tickets and it's on an international
break so we play just before the
international break and we win and then
the lads are going off on on their trips
with the internet the national sides
Rick hasn't got a game we've looked
everywhere Dave David Kemp has rung
people up and but he's going away he's
got his bags packed so you know I'll say
to Rick Rick it's not gay mate what are
you doing she said no no there's a
friendly game they've arranged a
friendly game so I spoke to the manager
who the manager was I don't know I
haven't got a clue but there's a game
so oh okay can't be let him go let him
let him have a week away he's gonna be
good with big game when he comes back
let him have a week away so off he goes
um so I said Rick Monday you know you've
got your game the first week make sure
you're back in and then it's preparation
big player for us yeah yeah
don't worry about me I'll be back okay
if we get in on them and do we we have
that free week and then we get in on the
Monday for the preparation for the for
the Wolves game so we're getting no
Ricardo
Tuesday no Ricardo I'm going absolutely
partly I've got Dave Watson who's
official who's got his number he's
ringing him he can get him now and then
and then it breaks down and then he can
get him and
it's got to come in Thursday
no Ricardo
Friday no Ricardo so I'm absolutely
there's a game on Saturday as well yeah
absolutely livid so we prepare for the
game by having pre-match at the Bet365
stadium so it's only 40 minutes down the
road to wolves so everyone's in at 12.
then at past 12 we're going to get off
and get to the game so Rick walks in
you know he's got his hat on the side of
his head he's wobbling away and all the
players have completely disowned him
they're on that there's a table there of
all the lads and he's walked past the
table and he's tried to get a a an
acknowledgment from someone and they've
all blanked him and he's walked up there
and there's a little table at the top of
the room when he's by himself he's got
his beans and his eggs and easy so I'm
like with kempion I'm going I'm going to
kill him I'm Gonna Act he's going with
me Dave's my assistant Tom
leave him we'll need him we'll need him
I've picked the team he's not in he's
not starting so yeah I've come Kemp he
can get away with what he's got away
with and he's gone leave him just leave
him so he gets up all the players leave
get on the bus we're still sat here so
we get up so I go all right mate so he
goes yeah yeah he says sorry Garth he
said I've been in and out of Miami I'll
cut you know a wrong passport wrongness
wrong no oh Rick let's just go so he
honestly wobbles
having a corridor and I'm looking at
Kempy and going he's not going to be no
good for us today can't be says just
stick him on the bench and I say we go
stick him on the bench
so we got one nil up one each
uh and then it goes
um two one two us two each and they have
they're playing down the slope now and
they are battering us you know they mix
manager they're getting balls into the
box show across a new field up and call
to your head in balls out of
everywhere you know it's like
so kempty turns me he goes get him on I
said David you can't get him again he
said this is this is made for him so
it's full house there so he runs up that
that to warm up runs up the side of the
pitch and he gets at the top of the
pitch and he's turning he's talking to
the support
okay
it's all over if we don't get it
he's chatting away and you know hello
supporters
and it can be get him on so he comes
down
um drag someone off and he goes on we
defend a corner someone heads it out uh
Rick's not where he's supposed to be
right he's right on the edge of the Box
picks a ball up
dribbles past two or three players
Smashes in the top corner
three two runs down the pitch all the
players are jumping on him and cuddling
him and kissing him and everything else
two minutes later
another one does some magic passes it to
Liam Liam smashes it in or it went that
way we end up winning four two
so I'm I'm washed out I'm completely you
know he's done my brains in before the
game and then I've had all the emotion
of the game and it's a dabby and this
that and the other and we you know we're
up against it but we win so I get an
address room and I always yeah I'll just
say listen that's fabulous it's a
important result and you were fantastic
no problems so sit in the corner I'll
take my cap off and I'm like a bathing
sweat I I can remember I'm like this and
all of a sudden he gets up
and he walks across the dressing room
comes right next to me puts his arm
around me and says Gaff and I go Rick
and he goes
you worry too much
I go
and he went that's why you got no air
mate
and he just left me walked across the
room in his little Jake
that was and then you know the lads you
know everybody everybody wanted to be
around Rick then you know they hated him
before the game for what he'd done after
the game so forgotten it's amazing do
you know what I'm saying when you were
describing uh a while ago you're
describing Glenn wheel and then you were
like using different character
attributes you could say that he's a bit
of a fighter he's got a fighting no he's
what he's a cow he's a proper cow you
know he's a pro he's got that um he's
got that desire that inner desire
um you know it wouldn't surprise me if
Clayton one day became a very very good
manager great that was a good man he's
just got that um he's got that
personality in that character when
talking about Glenn wheeler if I were to
say brex shay
Brett yeah that that was that was an
interesting one because the the the the
great thing about Brett was I don't know
you've most probably heard the story of
you I know that something happened yeah
there was a I think it was Brett's first
training session at the club and we had
everybody knew the rules so if someone
fell over there was always two or three
people there to pick him up nobody got
on anybody's backs we'd always look
after one another it was that we had
that Spirit within the camp and we we
did a training session 11 against 11 and
Glenn miss it Crossfield pass
and Brett didn't know what the spirit or
what the the characteristic of the club
was at the time and he put his hands up
in here just went oh
anyway I'm looking over there next thing
I know Glenn's over there sorting him
out he never ever ever do anything like
that again at this football club we
don't criticize one another we get on
with things did he get physical or was
it just more work I can't go into that
but it was it was yes I understood I'll
just say this Brett never ever put his
hands up
oh it's amazing and I'm talking of like
leaders and you know on the pitch and
off the pitch
um Brian shawcross always pops up in
being a great leader well we had we had
um begovic was begovich Shaw cross and
uh Robert hoofie
um you know we had Abdullah five for a
while as well that that triangle of
strength and then like you see put Glenn
and Dina or whoever in that Midfield
that that was that was really rock solid
and and proper characters and Ryan I
made Ryan Captain when he was only I
think 19.
um
it's a good story with that one as well
so we
I ring it's pre-season I go and watch
Ryan play for Manchester United thirds
up up
um one of the the non-league clubs in
around Manchester so I race up on a
Saturday I think it was a one o'clock
kickoff we trained early raced up there
watched him then when I watched him on
the Tuesday night at another non-league
ground around Manchester then run run to
Alex up could we take him you know give
you a long take the long fee off if we
sign him so we agreed I think a million
or two million whatever it was anyway we
signed him
um and his first game was at Cardiff
he's 19 years of age and we went to
Cardiff and won one nil and Ryan's gold
and that was the promotion year and for
a kid he played with Courtney then
um Leon Court and for a kid of that age
to go through a season to get promoted
and play the way he played it was just
fabulous and he got he got more
confident and more confident and more
confident as he went on yeah yeah great
lad so any specific examples of where he
was a good leader well I'll I'll tell
you one thing I did do to him which was
really really out of order but it was
because he was the captain we played I
think it was Blackburn and Sam was
managed at Blackburn at the time we went
to Blackburn and we played exceptionally
and I mean exceptionally well
um and we'll tune it up at half time you
know we scored a great goal from the
goalkeeper through it out to Matty Matty
went down the wing bit a couple of
people crossed it and crouching edited
the back post with two nil up and with
about a couple of minutes to go
um Ryan kicked the ball out of play you
know he could have played it up the line
but he kicked it at the play and the the
referee blew his whistle as I'm walking
down the side of the pitch
um I said to Kempy this is
this is the best we've played and Dave
turned to me and went yeah we got to be
a little bit careful now you know with
the complacency so I said no I've got it
mate I've got it so I walked in I I went
into the toilet went into the bathroom
as I always do and then they're all
chuckling away and everybody's happy
with everybody else it was really top
class first half performance
and I went in and I thought I'm I'm
gonna go for it so I picked on Ryan
because he was my captain and I
absolutely handed him for kicking the
ball at a play and I just said you know
you think we're tuning up you lot think
you're tuning up you've you've done it
this is Blackburn Sam's a top manager
you'll have them roaring second half if
you ain't on it and you've just shown
that you've dropped you know that
standard that we would we'd set and did
absolutely hammered him
anyway we went into the bathroom before
we go back out for the second half and
I've got John Wall to uh Jonathan
Woodgate and Matt yupson next to me and
Woody turns to me and says gaffer he
says whatever you do don't put me on
please and I said what he says I can't
play as well as what Ryan's just played
and I just looked at Woody and smiled
and walked out and then on the Monday I
pulled Ryan in and just said
you got to take one for the team there
son there was I thought you played
really really well but you had to take
it did he get it was he on board with it
well I think he had a bad weekend
I think he recovered on Monday after I'd
spoken to him but it's not like ill
feelings but when you get that kind of
dressing down there's no like I think
there's a I think there's you know I've
fallen it with loads of people and loads
of players and everything else you know
you know I had Andy Griffin me and Griff
fell out right at the end
um you know we wanted to play more
football
um and I I don't blame him for that
because the top player we had a bit of a
Fallout but have I did I have respect
for griffia enormous respect
um great great lad again another winner
wanted to you know really give
everything for the football club Local
boy
um and you do you have those you know
you have those moments in management
um I think it's less so today but I
think you know there was confrontation
um or a little bit of Confrontation then
sorting things out and getting things
done properly you know you're always
challenged as a manager you're always
challenged whether it's what you what
you're doing to prepare the players or
you know things that they don't think is
necessary
um and you know the I think there can
only be you know one singer and one song
If you're going to be successful
um and that's you know that's always
been my
um my way and my attitude really you
always had a very good relationship with
Matthew everington Matthew was Matthew
the Elijah should say it was my
teacher's pet yeah teacher's pet and
everything else Matty was I thought
Mattie was an outstanding player we took
him from uh Tottenham
um and he'd had one or two issues off
the pitch
um I think he's gone into that himself
and I think people know
um I I just I I it's balance when he was
on song his balance and the pace and the
quality of crosses he got in
just exceptional like I said we're very
very fortunate to have
um for a good period Matty and Jermaine
Jermaine was again a very very clever
player with the ball and the quality he
had as well was was fantastic but now
Matty was he was a little Winger amongst
a lot of big people playing in that team
and he got spoiled and did you did you
get a little ban like in the changing
room with like he'd call him and
teacher's pair or was it just a bit just
just now and then they they'd bring it
up if you know if I set everybody in on
Monday apart from you Matt you can have
a day off
you weren't too happy with it
um
that you know that little things that
I'd let him off for I'd say yeah you
know we were absolutely rubbish Saturday
apart from you man
a little twinkle in his eye but he was
one you had to keep on sorry you know
some you can kick others you have to
cuddle and you know get nice management
then any transfer regrets
um oh there's always people that you you
try to sign you know we we had Alonso in
um uh no uh the lady was at Chelsea and
Marcus said Marcus we had him in from
Blackburn I think he was at Blackburn
and then we well was it Bolton Bolton
sat him in and never signed him and then
he went on and did fantastically well
he's a lovely kid as well lovely kid uh
people like that yeah there's there's
people we've missed surgeon abery
um yeah that I I I I'll say this again
and I've said it loads of times we'll
start with the fact that ganabri was at
Arsenal for four years so he's an
Arsenal player he had arsenfinger there
as his manager four years and then they
loaned him out and they loaned him out
because they couldn't get anything out
of him if he was doing well he'd have
stayed at Arsenal but they couldn't get
nothing out of him so he came to us
Baldi rang me up Steve bold is a great
lad X obviously still player and he said
he's worth it worth he's got loads of
ability but we we're
which end with him he came and didn't do
very well
um and that year I think we finished
10th well we're definitely in a top
tenant and we had people like Morrison
brunt real good players and so it's just
it just didn't fit into the group a
matter of fact there was a reserve game
against Aston Villa
um and Jimmy Shan was was uh took it it
was the reserve team manager and we used
to let you know we'd say we want those
players to play and then we let Jimmy
take it and Darren Moore and people like
that
um and I never watched that game I
actually had I think I was home for some
reason
um it was on a Monday evening and when I
rang Kent he went to the game when I ran
Kemp yeah and asked him
Jimmy had taken him off I don't have
time he was he was that bad and then
when he went on you know the Arsenal
then he went back to Arsenal Arsenal
then sold him to third Bremen you know
so I think Van Gogh maybe didn't see
what we didn't see yeah we get hammered
for having him you know people say oh
blind me what a missed what they don't
think he wasn't our player
we just had him for a few months Wenger
had him all that period and didn't see
nothing in him so you know and Kempy I
can remember a great quote you know I
ring kempty up and say oh you know I'm
pleased the kid's done well you know no
no bad feelings towards a kid at all and
I think most probably the West Brom
going to West Brom and thinking he was
just going to walk in most probably gave
him the biggest kick up the backside
he'd had they sold him to Verde Bremen
and then he went on to obviously uh
Bayern and done wonderful things I can
remember ringing campy happen one day
and saying have you seen uh ganapri you
know he scored again for for Madrid uh
for Munich
and he said to me Tom it must be his
twin brother
it cannot be the lad we had and that
that that's serious you know it was
chalk and cheese it just finally on
Canaveral was it more of like do you
think it was a skill thing or was it do
you think it was a YouTube no I just
think he found it I I I there's
and I'll say this the first loan that a
player gets from the top three or four
club is always difficult for them
because they they are spoiled absolutely
rotten Arsenal Tottenham Chelsea go and
have a look at their facilities go and
have a look at you know the way they're
fed the way they're looked after you
know they're everything else they're
completely and utterly spoiled and
they're playing with
proper players and I mean top top
players and when you drop down just a
little level it's more difficult
to get that feeling that edge and I
always say if I'm taking if people ring
me up now and say there's a good player
to ask has he been out on Long yet has
he tasted it yeah right let him go
somewhere else and let him taste it when
he comes back
see if you can get him a second time
round or a third time round because
he'll be much more prepared for the real
battles than what they are playing under
21's Academy football
so I now need to ask you this this is
the one I've been waiting for James
Beatty
nude what happened here no well let's
put that that season if you if you
actually look at the season that we
signed
um and it was
um you know the uh winter window we
signed we were struggling at the time I
think we were third from bottom we
signed Matty Etherington and James
um and without without those two I don't
think Stoke would have stayed in the
Premier League so those two played an
enormous part the incident in the dress
room I will not talk about because I'm
old-fashioned and I believe what happens
in the dressing room happens in a dress
room but I'll say this be for when he
was with us he did fantastic and he kept
us in him and Maddie really was the
icing on the cake that kept this in the
league did you talk to him now
[Laughter]
this is your life
so Tony uh we are going to play a little
game with you it's called a glass or
pass okay so we're just going to give
you a manager and uh you know
historically famously people will have
you know have a drink with the managers
after the game so we're just asking uh
give your manager and you just tell us
whether you have a drink with them oh
yeah he'd pass and leave right so the
first one is Ian Holloway glass glass
what was it about Ian Holloway that you
enjoyed he was Godfather to my first
child oh so Ian Ian was a 14 year old uh
lad at Bristol Rovers when I first met
him he was about varai can you see that
it was neon
and obviously I I played and see me and
girl at Bristol Rovers so yeah he was
Godfather to my son Anthony Sir Alex
Ferguson glass
arsene Wenger pass
[Laughter]
yeah
anything no listen The Lads used to the
lads would go in and have a drink with
us and
um Kent he always went in the rooms I
think roji did as well and one or two
other people but I I did have the um
with him for what he said initially
um when we played at Stoke
um and
yeah you know we've we've spoken since
and we've been fine so we're better now
that we're not in the game can you find
us what was the quote the famous quote
um a class this is a rugby team and he
thought that throwing should be banned
and that you should just play with your
foot he's still doing he's still on that
one about the throne you know you've
left the sky you know in his role now in
his role now he's he honestly thinks
that
throw in puts the team that win the
throw in at a disadvantage and he
therefore thinks that it should be
something else yeah send him the tapes
of Stoke City yeah yeah
[Laughter]
old glass yeah did you would you rate
him as one of the top top managers that
you've ever come up against
um also one of the nicest people I've
met as well so I've luckily managed
against him a couple of times I got my
backside slapped a few times with her
team
um but he's a nice man as well he uh you
know he really impressed
um my staff
um where they were humble he is I know
nice he is yeah Jurgen klopp uh no that
was a pass never went in I never went in
at when I was on well when I was uh when
I managed that or took teams to
Liverpool before it was Kenny Kenny and
I'd always go and have a drink with
Kenny because I knew Kenny uh and the
family had a family room
um and then with Brendan I'd always go
in and have a drink with Brendan
um but with clock it just you know
foreign managers some foreign managers
don't have that same coming of a drink
reversion you know it's different for
them so now we didn't uh we didn't see
Club what about Jose Mourinho a glass
yeah he was he was up for a class one
was he I heard something about Jose
Marino I don't know if this is true or
not but I heard that if he liked the
opposition manager he'd give them a
bottle of Portuguese wine that he
himself yeah bottles oh did you okay so
you've got the nice stuff yeah did you
get the nice stuff the nice stuff yeah
love that love that um what about Alan
paju glass yeah yeah and what was Alan
Paul do you like as a manager also we
saw is I don't forget his Antics serve
in the FA Cup finals
yeah what was he like oh I I think pads
was
South East London boy you know he's
a bit smart
but no you know I again I I've you know
he was um he was at reading when I
started oh sorry when he started
um I was obviously further down the line
on Alan
um but now we've always uh we've always
gone all right yes and finally Sam
allardyce glass yeah bottle
package
Tony thank you so much unfortunately
we've run out of time so we would love
to have you back on at some point to
talk about West Bromwich Albion and
Crystal Palace but for now we're gonna
have to say goodbye and thank you so
much to Tony polish
foreign
[Music]